[Music]
[Applause]
Mike gock co-host of Gojo and gock he's
not soft you can find that on DraftKings
Network also Big Mike will be on the
call Sunday's wild card game Westwood
won Packers Cowboys kickoff at 4:30
Eastern what do you make of the weather
conditions here and what role they play
in the outcome of either of these games
Kansas City or Buffalo Mike yeah they're
not moving the game I mean it's the
thought process of just what you said
Dan having everybody oh yeah it's a
horrible snowstorm now get in your car
and drive to Cleveland I mean it makes
zero sense at all uh the high that day
the high that on tomorrow in Buffalo is
44 and then the high on Sunday with the
day the game is played is 28 wind will
have an effect certainly the snow we'll
wait and see you know as far as Kansas
City and Miami um it's going to be cold
the coldest game I ever played in was
windchill 10 below when I was playing
for the Eagles we played in the metal
lands and Dan you can't prepare for it
you you can't you can't practice in it
you can't simulate what it's going to be
like you just have to go once you get
there before the game when you're going
out there it's now a question of of is
there snow on the ground is there not is
the ground just hard what kind of cleats
am I wearing sometimes in bad weather
like this you wear tennis shoes in all
honesty if this if there's not like snow
on the ground because your cleats won't
won't dig into the ground so you'll go
out and you'll check that out everybody
has to be careful with their steps
offense knows where they're going so you
can turn a short play into a Long play
because the defense slips it also I
loved bad weather because I was an
average athlete and it brought everybody
down to my level Miami is a Ferrari and
a Ferrari doesn't you know run well in
snow and cold weather so the one thing
I'll say though Dan outside of players
being used to warm weather and going to
cold weather the running attack for
buffalo with mostard being back and hhan
I'm telling you that could prove very
beneficial for Miami success On The Run
Short play action passes to waddler
Tyreek kill so that's what I would
expect there and the other side running
the ball as well with Pacho running
games going to become real important
tight ends real important and obviously
Casey a big Edge there with uh with
Travis what is it like to go on the
field and then in a cold weather game
and then you see that the offensive
linemen don't have sleeves on so one of
the more stupid things I did in my
nine-year career is I never wore long
sleeves and even in that game you know
we thought this Macho thing which is so
ridiculous Dan to sit there and think
that a guy in professional football is
going to look at another guy and say
he's not wearing sleeves oh God I don't
want to play against him is just a
ridiculous thought yet we all did it as
a dline I remember in that game in the
metal lands and then we went in the
locker room and came back out and a few
of the guys put sleeves on they're like
screw this I'm not doing it I left them
off which was just ridiculously dumb TV
timeouts are the worst because you're
standing there on the field kind of
ready to go the worst thing that
happened there this is back in the 80s
so they had like those engine like jet
engine heaters on the sine that blew out
the Flames I didn't wear gloves then so
I I put my mouthpiece occasionally warm
mouthpiece this game I did and I kind of
hooked it on my finger and I remember
not thinking my hands were freezing I
put them in front of the flame and my
mouthpiece my mouthpiece melted around
my finger so I mean it it was brutal and
back then you know that AstroTurf is
horrific you know no matter where you're
playing this again was at the metal
lands I mean it hurts like hell when you
land so like I said you can't prepare
you just have to go and and unless
you're heating your helmet on the
sideline don't ever take your helmet off
because it's like a brick putting it
back on let's look at these games the
coaching not vacancy but coaching
situation where a loss this weekend
would open up a coaching vacancy with
these
teams it's stunning but I mean we're
talk about this all the time with the
Cowboys don't we and you even heard
Jerry Jones say it last Monday after
they clinched the two slot is he was
asked about McCarthy's future and he
said we'll take it game by game in the
postseason I mean it's it's just
stunning but there's no other coach I
think that's going to be on any kind of
a hot seat uh going on these into these
playoffs save for I know they talked
about syriani I don't buy that one bit I
just think it's it's Dallas and I I I
and again I don't know why but if for
some reason they lose this game and I'm
looking forward to calling it that might
be the end for Mike which we we've been
talking about this every year right
because they've been talking about it
every year how are they going to replace
Mike or when are they going to play
replace Mike McCarthy we also talk about
these teams like the Texans and um Green
Bay oh they have nothing you I mean you
know nothing to lose here but you do
have something to lose you have a
playoff game the Texans are at home I
know they're underdogs and Jordan love
was second in the NFL in touchdown
passes he expects to play I don't I
don't buy into that and and you've
played in these games that where hey we
have nothing to worry about or Nothing
to Lose I'm thinking but you still do
don't I don't buy I I agree I don't buy
into that at all you know you hear that
term sometimes you're playing with house
money no you're not you're in the
playoffs we've seen nine and seven teams
get into the wild card and win the Super
Bowl so I mean it's all about getting to
the dance and you have a chance so I
completely agree with you Jordan love in
the last eight games is 18 touchdowns
one interception their offens is playing
well they got the you know the running
back situation getting somewhat squared
away with injury they have the youngest
basically set of wide receivers but
they're producing incredibly well their
defense against you know the run will
see a little bit about that it's been a
little spotty if par can take advantage
of that but I'm with you and then CJ
starden what they've done you know first
year head coach first year quarterback
first year play clawler and slowick even
on defense first year player and
Anderson seven sacks but but their
expectation why the hell would they say
oh God we're happy to be here that's
ridiculous because you don't know when
you're getting back ask Dan Marino that
one you don't know you're getting back
especially all the way to the Super Bowl
like he went through so yeah those guys
do not feel that we're playing with
house money situation now we're talking
to Mike gock uh he is the co-host of
Gojo and gock on DraftKings Network and
he'll be on the call the Sunday wildcard
game between the Packers Cowboys on
Westwood One what do you make of uh the
bill bellich Patriots parting and gerod
Mayo being promoted from within well you
know good for gerod mayo and his agent
had that written into his deal right
that he was the next head coach yeah
listen Dan we've both been doing this
long enough we all know what Mutual
means right I mean Bill wanted to still
coach and Pete Carol wanted to coach in
Seattle but they were making moves and
I'm glad they ended it the way they did
both ways especially we're talking about
New England now uh because sometimes you
see horrible endings where someone's
been there a long time and it's a bad
ending and then never go back for a
while I'm glad they end ended this one
amicably um I I there's no bill would
have loved to have stayed there bill
will be coaching somewhere else now and
Gerard Mayo listen it's a linebacker
world now right Deo Ryan at Houston you
got Antonio Pierce maybe getting the gig
to stay uh with the Raiders but this guy
was a film junkie when he played stayed
got their first was there last watched a
ton of film in the off season remember
on his draft day remember he was taking
number 10 overall he was raking leaves
at his folks place he wasn't in New York
you know I mean this is just kind of a
real blue collar guy that will kind of
carry on the bellich way I don't say the
Patriot Way it's the bellich way kind of
carry it on but kind of hopefully
modernize it as well so uh and they'll
hit the ground run and they'll hire from
within I'm sure from a GM situation so
they're from from that transition they
won't skip a beat but then they're going
to have to do what most bad teams have
to do they got to find a quarterback I'm
wondering if playing for bill bich is
something free agents would want to do
felt like they wanted to play for New
England when Tom Brady was there because
that guy was going to have them in the
playoffs and maybe a Super Bowl is if
Bill bich goes to Atlanta are free
agents all of a sudden going to go I
want to go play for bill bellich Dan I
don't think so no I mean you saw what
happened when Tom Brady went to Tampa
free agents went to Tampa right uh as as
much as bill is the goat and bill needs
15 more wins to pass schula and Tom is
the goat I have always said this players
have end up with more responsibility
because they're the ones that have to to
execute the plays on the field but what
bill has done has been fantastic but we
have also heard players say you know
what I went there to win a title not fun
not a vacation spot and and that's okay
that's okay not everything is fun in
life um but you had a great chance to
get a ring and that was the goal as a
professional football player in the team
aspect so you had the chance there
because of the team now he's going
somewhere if he does go to Atlanta
that's looking for a quarterback at
starting over a little bit no you're not
going to get because you know he didn't
they didn't pay real well while you know
to players in New England they weren't
they weren't about that so I I do think
it will not be like oh yeah I'm GNA go
play for bill because I'll I have a
great chance to win a title it may take
a bit I was more surprised that Seattle
and Pete Carroll moved on than I was New
England and belich yep and then even
brael that was a little more surprising
that felt like it got personal between
the owner and the coach
and maybe he was becoming a little too
high maintenance I'm I'm trying to
figure these because Pete Carol still
wants to coach yes and obviously Vel
does which one was more surprising for
you Vel uh Vel they were both surprising
to me but uh yeah I hadn't really
thought I know there were Whispers of
the vable situation because the last
couple of years had been under 500 or or
and had been more struggles than what he
had had but I never heard anything about
Pete Carroll uh the varable thing again
I agree with you I think high
maintenance Andor wanted to have too
much voice the the
statement by you know um the the owner
now Amy why why I can't thank you Amy
Adams because Bud was the owner when I
was with the Houston Oilers this his
daughter Amy I mean you want to talk
about a corporate statement I didn't
even understand some of the words in
there but basically the meaning was we
want to spread sprad the wealth we want
to spread the you know the power in this
organization and we want to modernize it
a little bit and I think they don't feel
that was happening with Vel um obviously
he'll get a job easily and Pete Carrol
kind of hanging on to that on his
Wikipedia page that already has he's an
advisor to Seattle I think he'd rather
be a coach somewhere but Dan this is the
amazing thing you got eight slots open
right now you have a 72y old head coach
a 71y old head coach you have Vel out
there you have Dan Quinn out there you
have the possibility of Jim Harbaugh out
there before you even get to the big
time OC o o coordinators and D
coordinators like the Ben Johnson's of
the world so it's going to be
interesting where owners want to go with
these older coaches who have had
unbelievable success or are you skewing
younger given where we are kind of in
the league now this just in from Adam
shefer uh the commanders are hiring the
49ers assistant GM Adam P Peters as
their GM he won Super Bowls while
working in New England and Denver he's
been in San Francisco since 2017 so uh
all right you know well I mean step I
think that's interesting because is the
way of the NFL going that way now to how
uh Shanahan coaches how McDaniel coaches
how uh really Dan Campbell but the O
coordinator Ben Johnson where we're
seeing a ton of motion and ton of
movement that seems to be kind of the
new way of the NFL and with that
movement from San Francisco to
Washington you wonder if that's what
they want to get maybe even go to a
younger coach you know they had that
search committee out there that included
Bob Meyers you know from the Golden
State Warriors so I wonder if that's
kind of a Direction they want to go
before I let you go uh give me the
reason why Jim Harbaugh would stay at
Michigan um that's a great question uh a
bag a big bag of money remember he
didn't sign his extension uh so now I
mean it's going to be whatever he
basically whatever he wants I I guess
you would stay for comfort you know he's
been there what nine years three years
now in the playoffs and he'll make he'll
make it pretty easily every year now
that you're going to 12 even if he
doesn't win the conference so the chance
to just be comfortable there but does he
want to accomplish you know the what
Pete Caroll did and Barry Switzer did
and Jimmy Johnson did national title and
Super Bowl cuz what did he talk about I
can finally sit at the big table at my
house with my dad Jack and my my brother
John now he can be the head man at the
table if he were to win a a national
championship like he did in a Super Bowl
what do you think he's gonna do I think
he's I think he's gonna go to the NFL I
think he hired Dan ye you know an NFL
guy um I I think he's G to make a move I
think he's going to get his choice which
you always look for where's the best
quarterback situation and that's with
the Chargers so I I would think he he's
going to move on great to talk to you
safe travels my best of the family thank
you Mike thanks Dan see you that's Mike
gock co-host of Gojo and gock and he'll
be on the call Westwood One radio
Sunday's wild card game between the
Packers and the Cowboys kickoff at 4:30
Eastern